nous sommes au Vélodrome national de 5qu
an en yeline à partir de ce jeudi 4
janvier il y aura les championnats de
France sur pis jusqu'à ce dimanche 7
janvier à mes côtés Nicolas André qui
est responsable événement à la
Fédération française de cyclisme et
Benjamin Thomas qui a gagné C titres de
champion du monde alors Benjamin comment
vous vous sentez à quelques jours du
début de l'épreuve même ça sera demain
même bah pour nous c'est un peu la la
reprise la rentrée des classes voilà on
est on est en tout tout début de saison
donc c'est les les premiers efforts et
ça permet de de bien lancer la saison
juste avant les les championnats
d'Europe qui seront la semaine prochaine
ça rendez-vous important pour vous ouais
c'est un point de passage important pour
voilà retrouver un peu les les efforts
de la piste après en hiver où on a fait
on a fait pas mal de routes donc donc
voilà c'est un point de c'est un point
de passage important et un bon pour bien
pour le début de saison Nicolas André
c'est un événement important aussi pour
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
c'est championnat de France oui c'est
c'est un événement très important sous
l'impulsion de Rousseau directeur du
programme olympique depuis 2 ans on a
replacé ces championnats nationaux pour
les élites au mois de janvier un peu
comme discipline hivernale et comme l'a
dit
Benjamin c'est très important pour pour
ce début de saison ils enchaînent avec
les Europes et on a à peu près 200 jours
des épreuves olympiques dans ce même
Vélodrome donc la Fédération tenait à
alimenter le ce qu'on appelle le Home
advantage et donc qui puisse faire une
dernière répétition sur sur ce vélodrome
en compétition et aussi qu'on attire un
peu le le PU public qui aura peut-être
pas la chance d'avoir des billets
Olympiques pour venir les encourager qui
sentent que que toute la France est
derrière eux pour aller conquérir les
titres si je comprends bien c'est
l'objectif de cet événement c'est de
monter en puissance avant les Jeux
Olympiques c'est ça c'est pas une
répétition pour l'organisation on a eu
les championnats du monde en 2022 pour
ça c'est une répétition pour eux sur sur
ce même Vélodrome ce même parquet et
pour la pour le public qui sente que ben
c'est une discipline qui ramène des
médailles chaque année pour le sport
français et j'espère que ça va être
encore le cas pour eux cette année à la
maison et donc c'est c'est important
pour la fédération de leur offrir cet
équipement pendant 4 jours Thomas
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de voir toute
cette équipe de France réunie ici au
Vélodrome national de 50 an Livine
c'est c'est enfin c'est bien on on a un
peu l'impression d'être en stage un
stage amélioré voilà après il y a une
forte
participation cette année je crois qu'
il y a beaucoup de de séries de
qualification dans chaque épreuve donc
ça montre vraiment que l'engouement et
puis puis pour nous c'est bien ça va
faire voilà des des compétition de de
haut niveau parce qu'il y a une grosse
denensité et et chaque épreuve sera
relevée quasiment sera quasiment le
niveau d'une d'une petite coupe du monde
donc nous c'est c'est super pour pour
travailler et et pour voilà comme comme
la Nicola faire une répétition une
répétition générale alors vous vous
connaissez parfaitement ce vélodrome
national de 50 an vous avez même même
vécu à quelques kilomètres d'ici à
attrape vous le connaissez parfaitement
ce ce vélodrome national 50 en Lig mais
est-ce que quand même on continue à le
découvrir au fur et à mesure des
entraînements ici bah en fait on va dire
que les quand on a pas fait quand on est
pas venu depuis plusieurs mois ouais les
premiers tours de piste on reprend des
nouvelles sensations mais après on
reprend on reprend très vite les repères
et c'est vrai qu'on on connaît cette
piste on connaît cette piste sur le le
bout des doigts on en connaî on connait
les les les virages les les les lignes
droites et cetera donc c'est c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment notre notre
piste
et mais voilà après en course on a
toujours des sensations un peu
différentes parce que il y a
l'atmosphère il y a le public et cetera
donc on prend c'est une piste où on
prend beaucoup de plaisir vous discutez
peut-être entre pistard de de cette
piste des choses peut-être à améliorer
vous discutez un petit peu entre vous ou
pas bah il y a une grosse recherche qui
a été faite par le le le pôle
performance de pour les pour les j donc
on est on a vraiment un programme de
développement axé sur que ça soit les
relaiss en américaine les relais en
poursuite par équipe les trajectoires
adopter il y a vraiment un travail qui a
été fait là-dessus on a rien qui est
laissé au hasard et ça c'est un petit
avantage par rapport à des nation qui
qui ont seulement disputé on va dire les
les championnats du monde ici ou les ou
les championnats d'Europe dans le passé
nous on a l'avantage de pouvoir
s'entraîner ici de tenter des choses de
tester des choses voir si ça marche et
et arriver le jour le jour J avec voilà
ce petit avantage ça peut être rien ça
peut être quelques diièmes mais ça peut
faire la différence sur sur des
poursuites et on le pefine sur ce type
de rendez-vous ouais ouais on le
peaufine ici en stage on le travaille on
le travail on aura au moins jusqu'au jeu
4 à 5 rassemblements ici d'une semaine
donc donc on va on va pouvoir on va
pouvoir vraiment travailler dans des
super bonnes conditions Nicolas André
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait vous de voir
cette équipe de France ici réunie pour
ces ces championnat de France c'est pas
courant non c'est pas courant ça fait
plaisir hier on était en montage on a
anticipé très tôt parce qu'on savait qu'
qu'il venait s'entraîner une bonne
partie de de la matinée donc on voulait
pas les déranger ça fait plaisir d'avoir
les meilleurs on a 142 engagés comme
disait Benjamin on a une densité assez
forte pour ce Championnat et on a on a
tous les meilleurs qui seront là pour
disputer 16 titres nationaux durant ces
4 jours 10 pour les endurants et 6 pour
pour les sprinters euh bah ça fait
plaisir et j'espère que ça fera plaisir
au public qui qui s'est mobilisé qui
sera présent sur sur les quatre journées
il y aura quasiment que des épreuves qui
seront aux Jeux Olympiques on est
d'accord c'est ça on a privilégié un
programme bien sûr avec avec toutes les
épreuves olympiques au programme donc
quatre épreuves olympiques pour pour les
endurants et trois pour pour les
sprinters euh ben le but c'est de
préparer les Jeux et donc c'est c'est de
leur offrir un programme
qui va avec et pu on espère qu'ils
trouveront comme le dit Benjamin les
meilleures sensations et monter cresendo
en puissance pour pour le mois d'août
comment on fait pour venir sur cette
épreuve si on n' pas encore son ticket
dans le public he bien sûr alors bah les
achats en ligne se font toujours he sur
l'espace de de la Fédération je rappelle
un tarif privilégié pour les cantinois à
5 € tarif pour les licenciés FFC aussi à
5 € gratuit pour les moins de 12 ans et
15 € pour pour les autres et il y a un
pass weekend samedi diimmanche à 25 € il
reste des places on sera environ à à
1000 1000 spectateurs surtout sur
vendredi samedi mais il reste de la
place sur les 4 jours donc venez
nombreux les encourager ils ont besoin
de VOUS Benjamin l'a dit hein c'est très
important de se mettre en situation de
compétition avec les encouragements avec
le stress plus il y a de monde plus il y
a de pression et donc ben je compte sur
sur chacun pour venir les voir dans
cette belle préparation la nouvelle
tenue l'homogénéité de de cette équipe
de France qui va aller jusqu'à jusqu'à
Paris 2024 et il y aura des épreuves
avec du suspense ah oui oui ben Jamin a
dit il y a il y a de la concurrence donc
même on va dire pour pour ceux qui ont
les références qui qui vont bien ils
auront de l'adversité et c'est ça qui
est qui qui contribue à la préparation
il leur faut de l'adversité et il y en
aura donc venez venez observer tout ça
Benjamin Thomas un petit mot pour ceux
qui n'ont pas encore réservé leur place
pour ce rendez-vous il y aura du
spectacle oui forcément voilà comme
comme l'a dit Nicolas on va d'habitude
quand on est sur des des championnats on
court un par nation là on va être on va
être en opposition et le niveau en
France est vraiment vraiment relevé donc
sur sur mes discipline en tout cas ce
que je peux dire sur l'Omnium et sur
l'américaine il y aura vraiment des des
beau du beau spectacle avec beaucoup de
suspense et des coureurs qui ont voilà
envie de on défmis dans les jambes voilà
les les sélections aussi pour les jeux
sont battent leur plein donc on est on
est beaucoup de coureurs pour pas
beaucoup de place donc il il y a
forcément de de l'adversité et mais
voilà ça c'est reste de l'émulation
positive
pour venir voir du spectacle il y a il y
a rien de tel et puis c'est sur le
weekend surtout il y aura il y aura
vraiment du public et cetera de
l'ambiance donc c'est si les gens
peuvent venir qui n'hésit pas et comment
ça se passe justement quand quand on est
sur la PIST sur des des championnats de
France comme comme celui-là on dit à son
copain qui est à côté ou on y pense pas
du tout on est vraiment dans sa course
oui on est dans sa course après voilà on
n'oublie pas qu'on est quand même on est
on est quand même on est quand même
collègue donc c'est toujours on fait
peut-être on est peut-être un peu plus
gentil on va dire sur des des
championnats notamment pas des coudes
voilà ouis on va éviter on va éviter ce
genre de choses principale c'est de
sortir de là avec avec une bonne
préparation et et être en pleine santé
après pour les pour les championnats
futurs et mais après voilà il y a pas de
il y a pas de cadeau à voir et on est là
on est là pour pour se tirer la Bour
entre guillemets et pas se faire de pas
se faire de cadeau et se faire plaisir
et Nicolas André il y aura des
marseillaises he tous les jours ici dans
ce blodrô national de 50 ans en Yveline
c'est ça la particularité de la piste
c'est qu'il y a il y a beaucoup de
spécialités donc beaucoup de titres
discernés comme j'ai dit 16 et chaque
jour ben on entendra les Marseillaises
et j'espère qu'elles raisonneront
jusqu'au mois d'août et voilà parce que
c'est c'est vraiment l'objectif pour
pour une fédération pour des des
sportifs qui qui qui se préparent pour
ça et donc bah ils ont à cœur de briller
dans 6 mois et et ben c'est la
répétition j'ai encore les frissons voir
l'ambiance du titre mondial de de
Benjamin dans notre dos là sur la ligne
d'arrivé il y a quelques mois et donc
ben on va essayer de faire perdurer
cette ambiance là dernière question
qu'est-ce qu'on peut souhaiteer vous
souhaitez à l'organisation pour cet
événement bah que le public soit au
rendez-vous ça contribue à la
performance et qui est comme l'a dit
Benjamin aussi pas de chute pas de chute
grave sur sur ce vélodrome que puisqueil
y a les Europes la semaine prochaine
donc ça soit sur le chemin de la
préparation on a toujours peur de des
incidents voilà en course et la piste
est une discipline quand même à risque
mais voilà on a les meilleurs ils
joueront pas complètement des coudes
même si c'est
[Musique]
voilà des tribunes remplies pas de chute
et et des beau beau vainqueurs en pleine
préparation pour pour les jeux de paris
merci à tous les deux ces championnats
de France débutent ce jeudi 4 janvier au
Vélodrome national de C50 Anvin et vous
l'avez compris il reste encore des
places pour assister à l'événement
jusqu'à ce dimanche